[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we hang out to have a
conversation about your life about your
money I'm your host today I'm Jade
warshaw and I'm joined by Rachel Cruz
thank you so much for being here guys
give us a call today the number is
Triple A
825-5225 we'll talk about whatever you
want to talk about we'll talk about
what's going on in your money your
budget maybe you're looking for a new
career maybe you're wondering if you can
be a stay-at-home mom maybe you're
wondering about this whole student loan
debacle whatever it is give us a call we
would love to hear from you so let's go
to tannin Tanner in Bentonville Arkansas
what's going on Tanner
hey how are you doing doing good how are
you
doing well
um yeah so I'm just calling about uh
trying to figure out how to my wife and
I should allocate our budget
um currently we're um we're investing
about a thousand dollars a month into
sinking funds we bring a home around 8
000 a month
um met and uh just trying to figure out
how we uh if we want to pay off our
house quickly how we should go about
doing that and if we're allocating too
much money into our thinking funds uh
what are the sinking funds for Tanner
um so uh mostly like travel uh Christmas
presents kids expenses some medical
emergency and like annual uh membership
renewals okay
and how much are you guys putting
towards the house right now
um we're just paying the the just the
mortgage payments so it's around 2 300 a
month okay so nothing on top of that
nothing on top of just the mortgage okay
um
and you have no other debt correct this
is
yes correct okay and putting 15 to
retirement
uh we're right now we're around 12 but
we're gonna bump that up here soon okay
so I would definitely bump that up to 15
before I started making additional
mortgage payments
um yeah so I mean you know we always say
that and you're intents through baby
steps one through three and then more
intentional baby steps four through
seven so even having sinking funds and
all of that Tanner I mean that's part of
you know the enjoyment of your life when
she paid off debt and you have your
emergency fund I just want to make sure
that something extra is going to the
mortgage because I think that will kind
of settle you just knowing hey we are
putting something towards this so we're
not going to have it for 15 years right
you don't want to stay in that habit for
too long now if it's just for a season
and you guys are like yeah yeah for the
next six months this is how we're going
to be but I get a raise in six months
we're going to allocate that like right
if there's something that's going to be
changing then I'm comfortable with you
guys as you are for just a few months or
so for a season
um but I wouldn't make this a habit for
years and years and years and years
because we want that house paid off too
yeah exactly make make sense yeah what
she's saying is it you want to enjoy the
money but at the same time if you're not
making a concerted effort or an
intentional effort to put money extra
money on the house however much that is
like for some people it's making a
double payment for some people it's you
know just a small percentage more
depending on what your finances are but
I love that you're even thinking about
this have you got money do you guys have
kids you have money set away for college
as well
uh yeah we have two uh 529s open
currently we just opened those so we've
we started investing that as well very
cool so I mean you guys are doing
everything right I think it's just
figuring out
um I'm the type of person yeah I'm the
type of person I like things to feel
automated like it's this much every
month yes and it's Clockwork I was gonna
say even Tanner and again you don't have
to do this today because none of this is
is urgent yeah you know here in the next
day we get some callers that were like
no you need to sell the car today
but what I would say is maybe you guys
try maybe in like I don't know two
months I'm just throwing something out
there to be like hey what if we put an
extra just like 200 200 300 and that
sinking fund goes down a little bit and
then we kind of have to reallocate live
on that for a little bit and see how
that feels and again if it's crazy
stressful you're like shoot we have a
beach trip we really need you know you
can kind of fluctuate it but just start
to try these things because so much of
this money management I have found Jade
is it's it's habits and like you said
when things are automated and they just
become a part of your life you almost
learn to live with it so if you guys
took that sinking fund to 800 put 200
extra a month towards the mortgage run
go to ramseysolutions.com and do the
mortgage calculator too and even that
math could be motivating oh wow maybe we
can actually decrease it to to 700 and
throw 300 at it because we'll get it out
you know we'll pay it off this much more
and that's to say Tanner this is a seven
year goal most people pay off their home
in seven years so in seven years from
now you're going to be making more money
yes who knows what life things are going
to happen so I do see progress happening
but I want you guys to try to live
a certain way for a bit just to see like
yeah maybe a little uncomfortable but
also gosh we're at least making progress
towards the house that's right how does
that hit you Tanner like and by the way
I didn't even ask you how much do you
have left to go on the house
um we we just bought it about a year ago
so we're at around 3 20ish right now and
what's your income like what's your full
um household income is around 140. cool
yeah this is exciting I love these
conversations when there's this Freedom
surrounding it you're not like Rachel
said you're not pressed to do anything
um right away I think this is really
really exciting and again it's just you
know what you said Rachel is so true
just like when you start budgeting for
the first time right you you get a hold
of this and you're like okay you don't
want to make like these drastic Cuts
right right away because you're never
going to see it's like you do a little
by little and you're like okay I'll pull
back on the groceries here I'll pull
back on eating out here how does that
feel okay great we can pull back a
little bit more here and it's the same
thing when it comes to
um tackling something like paying off
the house like you might say oh we're
gonna put a thousand dollars every month
but yeah let's let's cool out for a
second let's let's try with a little bit
first see if you can actually maintain
that and then if it feels right keep
going and be very intentional about that
and that's one of the things I love
about every dollar is you can do that
easily yes you can set up you know I
don't think a lot of people understand
this so when we talk about every dollar
it's our budgeting software here at
Ramsey Solutions and it's been around
for a while I've had it since it very
first came out and when it first came
out you couldn't do all the stuff that
you can do with it today like now you
can do the sinking funds in there
um you can do the irregular income in
there you can use it to even see like
what's your financial roadmap gonna be
over the course of time so when we talk
about these things it's very exciting
because you can see oh if I make these
payments this is how long it's going to
take me to get out of debt or this is
how long it's going to take me to save
my emergency fund or even this is how
long it's going to take me to you know
build up the retirement I want so I love
that he's yeah and it's it's amazing how
you know we said it earlier but how
habitual things are like you just you be
we're creatures of habit I think it's
just like the that that is a known thing
and so all of you even that are out
there listening that are trying to maybe
pay off debt or get your emergency fund
and there's still some sacrifices maybe
you're having to make or want to make or
even someone like Tanner that's like
yeah I'm here on baby step six but maybe
some small tweaks here or there you know
I think it's a great exercise to even
look at your budget and you mentioned
every dollar because Winston and I use
it and and even that Jade I'm like we
have our set categories that pretty much
go month to month we add probably four a
month depending on the month and you
know whether it's a trip or there's kids
sports fees or whatever right so some
things are added but overall it's like
we have our same we have our same
transactions basically our same bills
like everything is so similar that I we
pressured you know we kind of put
pressure on ourselves like golly we're
so habitual in this what if we took down
some categories right can we actually
live without it and the closest one
right now is cable
and he's like let's just live without it
for three months and see what happens
and I'm like I have questions though why
because the Real Housewife Bravo I don't
know I just I just like my stuff I like
my stuff so no I agree with you I would
have a hard time cutting it I'm like
dang I I live like no one else I get to
live like no one else I'm keeping the
cable
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up guys you're listening to the
Ramsey Show I'm your host today Jade
warshaw joined by author and fellow
co-host co-host and host of The Rachel
Cruz show Rachel Cruz uh give us a call
today if you want to we can chat it up
give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five and the question
of the day today is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
Home Improvement is not always about
repairs or remodels sometimes it's about
Comfort mosquito Joe service can handle
your outdoor pest control and make it
fun and comfortable to go outside all
season long I think that I need that
because the mosquitoes are tearing me up
on my porch terrible visit
neighborly.com to find a service near
you alright so today's question actually
comes from our baby steps Community
Facebook group
in my husband yes my husband is an
engineer and pays all the main house
bills including the mortgage electricity
and water he has a retirement account
and a nice emergency fund for our family
he has no debts he pays most of the
groceries and gas we have two kids so I
work part-time at a vet clinic and have
two other side hustles I do pet sitting
and have a small business where I sell
soap art and teach classes my small
business doesn't profit towards our
family yet since most of my income goes
back into the business I imagine I will
have profit next year I pay my own bills
and I feel like I just can't get ahead
because a lot of the large expenses are
Court related from a previous
relationship okay so do you have any
advice how to manage this I'm currently
not saving any money and I work my buns
off to pay these bills for them to just
kind of maintain where they are and I
can't get ahead wow okay well
this is
um yeah there's a there's multiple
layers we could go here Jade yes
um so my my highest layer what I would
say is it's a mantra we talk a lot about
on this show and that is that you guys
need to work together I mean you you are
acting financially here like roommates
that he pays these bills I pay those
that's what I literally did in college
when I lived in an apartment we just hit
like four things someone was in charge
of the paper towels someone in charge of
like I feel like everyone had their own
divvied up thing and that's how you live
this is not how you live with your
spouse with someone that you are married
to that you're sharing a life with and
that's for multiple reasons so we can
cut me off Jade because this is like no
girl you go girl but I'm like it is a
financial mistake number one we can go
there but I agree you just can't get
ahead financially as as this woman is
experiencing so it is harder to get
ahead financially when you are not
putting all of your money into one pile
and saying hey where are we gonna divvy
this up and you're working as a team so
the financial setback is very real and
then there's the emotional setback that
I think is very true now I always caveat
this if you are in a relationship that
maybe you're separated you it is a
heading you know you're gonna serve
papers or there's abuse there's
addiction like there are definitely
caveats that you want to protect
yourself instead of boundary we are 100
out of that but for the couples out
there that are just living their life on
two separate tracks just because in the
name of
trusts you know maybe maybe our trust
issues but or in the name of
Independence whatever the thing is yeah
we we beg you to be like we beg of you
we do we beg of you to say let's work
together because of that other aspect
which is the emotional side yeah that
when you see yourself as a team when you
trust the other person so much that
you're sharing a very very you know uh
valuable asset in your life which is
your money
but you're seeing you have that ability
to have that level of communication
trust intimacy that is created when you
work together so I agree and you know
like you said this originally came from
the baby steps community and the
comments were there was a lot of
comments on it and you know I think you
know one of them was like Hey I just
want Financial advice I don't want
marriage advice and so Rachel a lot of
times people do separate those
categories and they don't see it as the
same thing it's like no it's like that
compartmentalization of this is my
marriage this is my job this is you know
and it's like it's not really like that
all of that stuff bleeds together and
when you try to keep it so separate I
just have practical questions honestly
because I'm like really if you're in a
can I just play this out because
if I'm in a marriage and let's just say
I'm doing great I'm making my money you
know I don't have a lot of debt but
let's just say sam warshaw you know he's
not making so much money he's got a
little bit of debt and I say hey let's
go out to dinner
what does that look like am I am I
ordering the Tomahawk Steak and he's
ordering a side salad yeah and I'm just
eating and looking at him like well you
just need to get your money you know in
check what does that look like what does
it look like if one month it's just
tight for him and his side of the rent
or his side of the mortgage is or the
bills that he's supposed to pay the what
whatever yeah I just feel like that I
mean marriage has its own difficulties
yeah
I just feel like that would add such a
level of stress and strain and like you
owe me and you're you know like your
spouse could become your debt collector
your spouse could become the you know
what I'm supposed to yes yeah what a
horrible thing for intimacy in a
marriage to be like Oh I'm avoiding you
because I owe you the rent yep is this I
need people that take to the comments on
this because I need to understand is
this real is this what people are facing
um when they don't combine their
finances I'm like we share a bed yes
our children like our DNA is together
running around in this child right I
mean like there is so much here yes but
you won't put your five dollars over in
my account or you won't right come on
and if and if it is trust issues then
those are the issues that you need to
face because I hear so often Jade like
gosh you know and I still see it in my
comments all the time because I get so
much hate for this but people are like
well we fought all the time when our
money was together now that we've
separated we don't fight I'm like yeah
yep because you're avoiding the issue so
actually your fighting was creating some
level of conflict which in turn is some
level of intimacy of you actually having
to deal with issues such a good point
then just completely just just ignoring
it and so and what scares me about that
is we talked about in the first segment
how we're creatures a habit when that
starts to be in one area of your
marriage that you're compartmentalizing
like you're saying
you can't compartmentalize that it will
seep into other areas of your marriage
too so yeah there's just this um and so
if you are out there and and maybe you
know it's even like you know this lady
in the baby steps community that posted
this
and you can't you find yourself I can't
find my I can't combine accounts with my
spouse ask yourself why actually what is
it is it fear from a past relationship
because that's real people have gotten
you know screwed over in a divorce like
something has happened in the past let's
talk about that of course let's talk
about that for a second because
um I follow a couple of different I felt
several different Finance pages online
and one of them the girl I follow
um she's very
she very much wants to help women feel
empowered so they don't get screwed if
it goes down in a divorce yeah because
that's what happened to her yes and my
thing is like if you do this the right
way you shouldn't get screwed your name
if you are an active participant in the
finances
yes yes your name is on the mortgage if
you have the 401K He's listed as your
beneficiary if he has it you're you know
it's everything is handled to the point
where you're listed on everything that
you should be listed on along with him
so I don't really see how that argument
fleshes out of yes if there's a divorce
he'll clean you out or she'll clean you
out does that make sense yes and unless
it's it's a situation you know which I
know happens we've had callers on the
show where there is a level of major
control for one spouse there's abuse
that's played in that yes and they clean
out the you're right like like there's
that but if you're in that situation you
don't want to combine again that's right
what separate if you're in a marriage
that there's danger for you yes yes
combining accounts with a person like
that so uh but again yeah like you're
saying overall it it's so hard and then
another thing Jay that I hear this is so
tactical and so shallow compared
everything we were talking about let's
get it but someone I get this a lot too
well how can I buy a gift for my spouse
how can we that's great yeah that's
great so again on a tactile side you
guys get a Visa gift card okay well yeah
you know your anniversary is coming up
it's not like it's gonna be a surprise
like so talk about it or birthdays like
whatever like these most of these life
events are not surprises they're dates
on the calendar that you're both very
aware of or if it is you know something
that's secretive to say hey I and maybe
blow the surprise a little bit and just
say I wanna I wanna do something for you
this amount's coming out for a Visa gift
card just so you know I'm gonna go and
buy some stuff with like like there's
always so don't let that silly stupid
excuse stop you stop you from the
intimacy that's created and actually
having a marriage rear one I agree so
and I get a little sneaky I'm not gonna
lie I will go to the grocery store and
like under the guise of like the grocery
budget I'll take out a little bit of
cash back here and there so he doesn't
know because if he knows it's like oh
you bought a 200 gift card I know I have
a feeling of what you're getting so I'll
like sneak it out a little bit maybe
that's I don't know if that's
controversial here's your here's your
present Sam this is the Ramsay show
foreign
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
hallow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys you're listening to
the Ramsey Show I'm Jade warshaw this is
Rachel Cruz to the right of me if you
are watching on YouTube which so many of
you guys watch and listen to the show
there of course there's a podcast that
you can listen to on wherever you listen
to podcasts but did you guys know that
we're actually on Twitter as well
that is right the Ramsay show is
streaming on Twitter I didn't even know
this was possible Rachel I know I
haven't been on Twitter in a long time
Jake so I don't know either but yeah you
can watch it the ramsayshow twitter.com
the Ramsay show and you can also follow
us on Twitter
um either as the Ramsey show but all the
personalities are on there as well yes
yes so if you are looking for a place to
watch the show I highly suggest it
actually you know go watch the show
wherever you want to I just want you to
watch the show so whether you log into
the app whether you go on Twitter
whether you go onto the YouTube
um I actually prefer YouTube but we just
want you to watch it of course we want
you to share the show if you enjoy it
um share it with your friends talk about
it like it subscribe it all of that
stuff helps us uh it helps you and it
pumps it up in the algorithm so that
other people can see the show as well so
that is great without further Ado we're
going to Hartford Connecticut to talk to
Josh what's going on Josh
hey how y'all doing today doing good how
are you
oh perfect happy Friday uh thanks for
taking my call it means a lot and also
thanks for all uh you guys do for the
community most definitely thank you I
really appreciate it what's up uh so I
have a two-part question for you guys
today uh sort of regarding housing and
relocation so to give you a little bit
of background I've been in Connecticut
my entire wife and I finally had a point
where I'm looking to relocate down south
to a place you may have heard of called
Nashville come on Josh
everyone else is coming
that's what yeah yeah that's what I was
thinking so it's a beautiful spot I love
it down there I've been there so many
times so the first part of my question
is about that moving down to Nashville
do I go right out and buy a new house or
do I rent a house for a few years and
figure it out
um the reason I say a house and not an
apartment is because I have some side
hustles that require me to have a house
and I don't want to necessarily move the
income from that
um the second part of my question is
what do I do with the house I currently
have in Connecticut
um regarding do I rent it out while
living in Tennessee or do I just sell it
and walk away with the money wow I'm
curious first and foremost what what
kind of side hustles do you do that
require you to have a house I agree well
so so the main thing is I'm actually on
YouTube I do barbecue so I do like
smoking and griddling and all that good
stuff okay I know you can't necessarily
Park a smoker outside an apartment oh
gotcha gotcha gotcha that's great
yeah and then I'm also a drummer go
figure
um so you need a you can't be drumming
at at 10 A.M with the neighbor the
apartment neighbors banging on the on
the wall right yeah that's cool well as
long as your budget and your income
um allows you to have a house I'm good
with it but for some reason if you're
like no it's 80 of my income has to go
to a house you know a rent payment or a
mortgage payment I'd find another place
to drum and barbecue so these aren't
like yeah things that are exclusive I'm
assuming that you'll be able to get a
house and that's great if that's an
option but well I still like him renting
until the area yes yes so that's what I
would say for sure Josh is yeah rent for
a year because like any City and I would
say this with anyone moving anywhere but
oh yeah but you said Nashville
specifically I'm like okay well you've
got you've got Hendersonville you've got
East Nashville you've got Murfreesboro
you've got 12 South you've got Franklin
you've got right Ashland City like there
are so many just like majority of cities
that you're gonna find
uh so many parts you know of a city that
you want to know okay where do I need to
be location wise maybe for a job
um if you have to drive somewhere uh
what you can afford I mean all of it so
you want to know the area uh so
definitely rent for a year and again
that goes to anybody moving to any city
is to definitely rent and then Josh I
would I would sell oh yeah being a long
distance landlord is so far away no fun
no no fun and my guess is that if you
had started if you had started in
Nashville you wouldn't be like I want to
have a rental house in Connecticut like
that sounds like a dream you know
exactly so you don't want to hang on to
it just because you have it by default
and I'm sure it'd be nice to have that
money in yeah how much would the house
sell for how much would you be able to
walk away with
yeah so I I bought it for 222 in 2019
and I only owe 138 on it and I would
walk away according to my realtor with a
minimum uh you can sell them for 350 ish
so yeah about 180 200 hopefully that's
wonderful and so you could just park
that in a high yield savings account
while you rent and learn the area and
figure out you know what do you make a
Year Josh with all your um with all your
side hustles
um I would say conservatively
110. okay that's great and you're single
yes okay so it's just you yeah so I
think that's great I mean you're making
a great income it's just use you're not
having to worry about school zones and
like you know all the other things yeah
uh and so yeah you're able to to figure
out what fits in your life so I think
that's that's awesome so yep I would do
exactly what Jade said Park that
200 and rents uh keep that income coming
in and then when you decide to to buy
somewhere and to put a good down payment
you'll have you'll have some good
savings to do that I love it thanks Josh
for the call that was a great call uh
let's see what Demi's talking about
she's in Denver Colorado what's going on
Demi is it Demi or Demi
it is Demi you got it right here we go
okay that's right you don't say semi
tractor trailer truck you say
so you know I'm just saying I'm just
saying some of y'all got that okay
what's going on
uh well thank you thank you for taking
him of the student loans kind of coming
back into effect if applying for
repayment options is going to hinder the
progress that um my husband and I are
currently making on the baby steps
um yeah a little bit of background is
we're currently in baby step number two
and we're on lesson number four of
financial peace so we might learn more
about this in the future but um we had
so I had some money saved um to pay off
some of the student loans but then
unfortunately my husband lost his job
and as he's searching for a new job
we've kind of used some of that as a
buffer to make ends meet um because
we're still adjusting our budget how
much are the student loans
student loans are 14 500. okay and what
how much other debt do you have sorry I
kind of kicked in but I want to make
sure we get to help you before the clock
Runs Out
yeah no other debt is we just have 38
500 and that's just in family alone
how much you guys make a year
um so with just my income right now it's
50 000. okay and how long has he been
looking for a job
um about a month okay and in his what
was he what was he making his previous
job
um he was making kind of just under what
I was making but we were roughly
okay so around 100 total
yeah so without without his debt or I'm
sorry without his income are you guys
able to cover like basic bills minimum
like are you able to cover what it takes
to live
uh barely okay so you're definitely not
making extra payments
right yeah where exactly we're kind of
just making it through right now so as
I'm sitting here thinking come October
and looking at the amount that's going
to be due I that's definitely not in the
budget okay well I think to me what I
would say is between now and October he
either needs to have his full-time job
or he's going to need to have three side
hustles put together so I mean it's not
like you guys are going to be floating
with fifty thousand he needs to be doing
something because you guys have all this
debt right I mean you guys aren't in a
position for him
um to be looking forever and ever and
maybe it's him taking a job that is not
his favorite job for a year just to get
you guys through this process
um but I think him getting an income
between now and October is is necessary
and doable whether again it's a
full-time job or he puts together two or
three side hustles that he does but
bringing in something uh to be able to
help cover and put down this so yeah I
mean I wouldn't go for a replay I mean a
repayment option at this point because
you're not in this urgent State you guys
you've got time you have time and like
Rachel you put it beautifully get
something until you get what you want if
you need to be making some income until
he can ultimately make the income that
he wants to be making at the job that he
wants to have anything is better than
nothing and I mean you've got time you
know the interest is going to start back
in August and then payments resuming so
you've got a little bit of time here
don't panic I never want people to take
the repayment plans guys the lower the
payment the longer you're going to have
the loan and the larger that loan is
going to grow over time so try to avoid
that at all costs this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's going on guys you're
listening to the Ramsay show I am your
host Jade warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz
we are taking calls all day all
afternoon about your life and your money
so be sure to give us a call Triple
eight eight two five a five two two five
is how you can get a hold of us and I
want to tell you guys this if you're a
new listener and you want to dive deeper
into the Ramsay baby steps I want you
right now or as soon as you get a chance
to go to ramseysolutions.com and I want
you to click on that get started button
and we're going to just help you figure
out what's the best next step for you on
your financial journey and that's based
on exactly where you're at today so go
to ramseysolutions.com and click get
started so you can know what's up figure
out what it is that we're talking about
when we talk to you guys about the baby
steps when we use certain terminologies
if you're new to this whole thing Rachel
you could be like I don't know what
they're talking about what language are
they speaking right there I never read
The Total Money Makeover what even is it
you know so go to ramseysolutions.com
and figure out what that is because
there's so much information there you
it's just gonna blow your mind and it's
going to help you move forward no matter
where you're at today so that's how that
works in the meantime we're going to go
to Jen in Phoenix Arizona what's going
on Jen
hi
um I'm Jen and thank you for taking that
call I'm really excited because you're
welcome oh thanks thanks for calling how
can we help
so I'm in a Sticky Wicket and
um
we have like 45
000 worth of credit card debt and a
house with a lot of equity my
um my husband works uh he's a line
Apprentice like an electrical lineman
apprentice and he's working outside the
home right now in Albuquerque so we're
kind of paying for two households and it
got expensive and a little crazy and we
had three kids in like three years so
[Music]
um there's just been a lot of stress and
I need to know
like how do I get out of this do I so
the house that we have it's got and
moved to Albuquerque
what how long are you guys going to be
separated for for his job
um he's got three years-ish
Jen you got you guys this isn't gonna
lie this isn't gonna this isn't good
this is this would not be a good
situation to be in for three years it
was only three months then I'd be like
all right we can stick this out but yeah
why what's keeping you from what's the
mentality that's saying we're gonna stay
here while you go there explain that a
little bit
well he's living in an RV because he can
be relocated like at any time
so like what you said three years
yes and he will do this for three years
like he was in El Paso before now he's
in Albuquerque okay
in three years he will be relocated to
another city correct
yes minimum every six months okay so
here's how I would almost treat it Jen
it almost sounds again totally different
I don't get hated him for this but
almost like a military
it's like a military situation yeah and
we always we always tell military
families to rent especially while
they're active duty because they move
bases right very consistently and owning
a home you want to own a home for for
five years or longer just to get the
wave through you know the ups and the
Downs of the markets so uh I mean jyn if
I were you you got three little kids how
old are your kids
how much how much equities in your house
uh we owe 137 on it we have it's worth
like probably 400. oh my gosh wow okay
yeah I would oh Jen and a heartbeat girl
I would I would be look to rent two
rents okay yeah selling your house in
Phoenix you guys go rent a house in
Albuquerque so that you have your
husband in the mornings and at night uh
when he's home your family is intact
you've been you're in your kids can see
like a single mom yeah I mean that and
that it was ages speaking of moms with
little ones
you're exhausted like I don't even know
how you're speaking to us in full
sentences I know because it's so much
work like it's just so much so yeah I
would do that I would sell and then
that's gonna help you pay off this
credit card debt uh but also I want to
know Jen what caused you guys to go
forty five thousand dollars in credit
card debt
um I think it's just
um
I mean just like child care like I work
full-time okay
and have a lot of
um it's just been really expensive we
had a lot of kids and I honestly I think
I've been kind of in denial of just so
not really wanting to care about money
very much are you putting are you
putting bills on credit cards like are
you putting the bill for child care like
are you making inside with credit cards
yeah I I mean yeah we are making
payments towards them but it's getting
to the point where like they're really
expensive and we're exhausted and yeah
um Jen what do you what do you do for a
living
I I'm an account executive for
commercial insurance so okay how much do
you make I make like 90 000 a year okay
and how much does your husband make
about the same rate now but he's only
one lower 60 of his income he's only at
60 when will he be at 100 percent
in three years okay I'm a little
confused you guys have a I guess he's at
60 of his income but y'all make too much
money to feel this broke let's just put
it like that
um with these credit cards um I are you
actively working a budget or are you
kind of
just making it work every month are you
on every dollar are you plotting this
out is there a monthly plan
no yeah no that's okay gender that's
okay you're fine we're here to help you
yes don't don't be don't feel shame from
that yes because I think what Jade is is
pointing out is it I think you said it
Jen just to say your words back to you
that I think I was avoiding the money
situation because it just was it's it's
been so much it's just been too hard and
so uh what we want to be able to do for
you is for you to feel empowered to be
able to know what's going on because I
think part of the ignorance Jen is
causing a lot of fear and you don't have
hard facts in front of you and our
friend Dr John deloney always says facts
are your friends and you've been dealing
in a lot of feelings which is good and
it gets feelings right we're gonna feel
the feels but also you have to have the
facts to be that foundation for you so I
want you to hold on the line Jen because
Austin's gonna pick up and we want to
put you through Financial Peace
University you and your husbands it's uh
in every dollar plus which is our
budgeting tool and if we give this to
you Jen as a gift are you going to use
it
um yeah well you use it yeah you promise
US okay we want you to use this because
I want you and your husband I want you
guys to be on a page together because it
even sounds like and I could only
imagine Jen I'm like when your husband
is is working full-time in another city
you you are you're alone I mean there's
a level of isolation and being a mom and
you're trying to keep up the child care
trying to stay alive yeah all of this
like it's just a lot and so I think you
guys being on the same page financially
with the same plan yeah is going to be
very helpful but Jen you got to get to
Albuquerque girl yeah I don't know if
you have girlfriends in your life to
tell you but but Jade and I are here
y'all like you need to be you need you
guys need to be a family and I think
that's going to allow a lot more peace I
mean I'm not kidding just the presence
of having your family unit together and
you guys going through Financial Peace
University together you and your husband
like you guys are going to start to
build this Foundation to realize what
we've been doing isn't working this idea
of having a level of just I want to be
ignorant I don't want to think about it
which is very normal Jen people do this
is that's a very normal thing
but but where you where it's gotten you
how you guys have functions financially
at least where it's gotten you you're
not happy you're calling us I mean you
can't do much when you're in survival
mode and that's where they're at you I
mean your husband's gone you're at home
with these kids you're just trying to
get through the day the last thing
you're thinking about is making a budget
and you know what I'm saying like that
get yourself in a place where you're
where you can calm down you can breathe
everybody's safe everybody's good then
you can send it's like okay let's
because there's a truth let's just open
up the door to see the monster in the
closet yes and Jade feels this too I'm
like Jen I even think about your day and
I'm like you get home and you have to do
dinner for three kids you're doing bath
time you're doing bedtime I mean that's
a nightmare with two parents and then
three kids under three yes three two or
one so oh you have a lot on you just
know that too because that's that's a
lot so I think getting any level of
Peace Jen is really
going to help your quality of life and
what I what Jade and I can do from this
side of the of the call is encourage you
to be with your husband I would move and
I'm Brent in Albuquerque you guys get on
the same page financially and then all
the other stuff and the Dynamics of your
life and working and Chuck and all that
you guys work out those are puzzles and
there's big pieces in this big puzzle uh
but you got this Jen I would make some
big life changes it's gonna be
uncomfortable but I think at the end of
the day it's gonna help you I agree yeah
Financial Peace University definitely
the ticket and when it comes to
Financial Peace University you still got
to put in the work when it comes to your
life and your money you got to do the
work you can tell me that you won't do
it but do not tell me that you can't
with Christ all things are possible
never forget that this is the Ramsay
show
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
money your situation I am your host Jade
warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz host of
The Rachel Cruz show if you've never
checked that one out be sure to check
that one out as well
um we're taking calls all afternoon
about your life what's going on with
your money what's going on with these
student loans if you have anything about
student loans please call in today
because y'all I can go on and on about
the student loan situation it is more
because I want to help people Rachel I
don't want to shame anybody I want to
help you guys because I get it some
people are really feeling like oh my
gosh what is going to happen these these
these payments are coming back it's a
it's a reality that's that's hitting
yeah and it's very emotional oh right
emotions I learned that yeah on all
sides well yeah I mean there was this
carrot dangling out and so many people
and I hate that happen because Rachel
people's full Hope was in the fact that
maybe these loans could be forgiven and
to just have your hopes dashed like that
I hate that for people so if you're
concerned about that give us a call
Triple A
825-5225 but really you can call us to
talk about anything you want to talk
about as long as it's life money
relationships don't just call talking
about any old thing all right we got
Kayla from Minneapolis mini soda guys I
can't say these words Minneapolis
Minnesota here we go what's going on
Kayla
hi okay leave me a call how are you
doing
I'm good I
was like I'm never gonna get through so
thank you oh glad you did glad you're
here how can we help
um so my question is my grandmother is
getting older and my parents and sister
are taking a trip to go see her and they
are encouraging me to go and I'm having
a really hard time because we've kind of
been we're in babysit too and we've been
Dave ish for a bit but recently we've
been more gazelle and I'm I'm really
having a hard time like pausing to do
that and then I'm I'm wondering if I'm
gonna regret it so I don't know I just
needed some other perspective how old's
grandma
she's been in pretty good health
um
but yeah for sure what's okay no go
ahead uh how much is the trip going to
cost you Kayla out of pocket
I think probably around 500 that's not a
ton I'm mostly paying for the flight
um
and then my parents have like the car
and like the place to stay and
everything else secured so I just have
to kind of get there yeah
um but I'm I'm having
they they are making a vacation out of
it so they're going for a full week and
so in order for them to like pick me up
and need to go with them I have to be
like close to their time frame and I'm
having a really hard time with going for
a full week because I where does she
live right now where does she live
Seattle area okay well there's there's
Ubers in Seattle so you could go for I
guess she's in Eastern Washington so
she's five hours away from the airport
okay okay
so you're saying it's a difference
between basically your family being able
to pick you up and take you to the
airport that sort of thing
yeah so they're they want me to fly in
because they're they're going to be in
the Seattle area so they could grab me
and then we would drive to like five
hours together and then stay there and
then come back so I can shorten it by
like a day I'm just I don't know
if we're just spending the money on it
but then I feel guilty because I feel
like well you should go and see her okay
and then I also have are you close to
yourself wait are you close to your
grandma
do you have a real like are you going
because your family's telling you you
should go do this or are you thinking
like man I love my grandma this could be
the last time I see her I want to go see
her
just curious I love I love but I I
haven't seen her in like seven years
[Music]
what Jade's getting at is your
motivation Kayla needs to be for you not
to be guilt-tripped by your parents yes
to go and see her so I think it's a very
honorable thing
um you know we just actually spoke to
Winston's grandmother on FaceTime last
night and she's 95 and I'm just like oh
my gosh like like it is a it's a it's a
treasure to still have family
um you know at that age living so I
think it's amazing so I I do think Kayla
at 50 years old will not regret taking
this trip so even on baby step two we
say if there's a wedding and you're you
know you have someone in your family
getting married your brother's getting
married in a different like you you go
cheap you go as cheap as possible don't
go into debt and Kayla I would be
honestly I would be curious I'm almost
tempted just to get my phone out and
start googling for you I would be
curious a rental car rental cars are not
that I mean maybe maybe 200 Kayla yeah
for you to rent a car
um to do that or maybe even where she
lives you could do a one-ray rental
which sometimes is more expensive but I
would start to price out options and and
look but I think again what Jade said
earlier I think is very spot on I want
your motivation for this trip to be for
you not because you're pleasing your
parents out of some guilt right but but
if Kayla wants to go see her grandmother
who's 92 uh and that this is a great
time to go because your other family's
going and all this we're great with that
right if you just do it really
inexpensively and you'll and you'll make
the trip tailored to what makes sense
for you not my family's doing this trip
they're doing five to seven days I'm
doing five to seven days I'm trying to
be and then you're do you see what I'm
saying and then you're having to
coordinate with them and you end up
doing things that you weren't going to
do spending more money but if you're
like I want to go see Grandma and even
the oh sorry sorry shut up that's okay
if you're like I want to go see Grandma
I for me this is what makes sense I'm
gonna get there on a Monday and I'm
gonna leave on a Wednesday you know what
I'm saying make sure you're doing it for
you so that you plan the trip that makes
sense for you and then you leave it
feeling good about what you did there's
no guilt there's no uh expectation that
your family may have had from you yeah
and your flights Kayla you could even
you know not feel like you have to fly
the same airline your parents are flying
in the same time you may even price out
the air the difference of Airlines per
time can save you two or three hundred
dollars round trip so so yeah I think
you owning the trip more just for you
from a logistical standpoint
is going to make you feel not only just
more in control but also you're going to
have more control over your money and
what you're choosing to do so I think
that's that's important so I would go
Kayla uh but again I would do it more on
my own terms
um and tell your parents that I mean I
would I'd be like guys we're I'm we're
getting out of debt we're doing that so
I'm gonna go as cheap as possible I
don't want you know I would like don't
wait on me don't plan it around me just
y'all do y'all's thing I'll do my thing
yep yep
I'm just like I feel like if we go for
if I go for a whole week it's like a
week of me missing work and then my
husband has to miss his like second job
yeah don't go for a whole week
don't do it and and I have a baby and
I'm like stressed about being away from
the back girl do not go for a whole week
go for the amount of time that makes
sense for your life and your
relationship and being a mom yeah is
really trumps a lot of this too like
right if you're if you have a new baby
and you know you're not like and that's
that's become a priority than other
things that's a very real thing too
Kayla so a couple of things flying in
the mix yes but uh we're never gonna
tell somebody to not go see their 92
year old grandma let's be real we're
actually human we have hearts unlike
some people on the internet thing I just
know some people are hanging on the edge
of their seat like is Rachel and Jade
about to tell her not to go see her
dying Grandma of course not I know go
see Grandma like these things like you
said when you're 50 years old you're
gonna go oh I had that last moment you
know like that's those are things that
you treasure for a lifetime and money is
important don't get me wrong but it's
some things that are more important like
family this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
all right guys you're listening to the
Ramsay show I'm your host Jade horshaw
joined by Rachel Cruz and we just love
talking about money we like talking
about the things that nobody wants to
talk about it's very rare Rachel that
people want to talk about their debt
that they want to talk about how much
savings they do or don't have that they
want to talk about the things that are
stressing them out but on this show you
can call in and we can open up the
closet door look at the monster figure
out what's going on and hopefully help
you solve your problem and that's the
key we're just here to help you you are
the secret sauce in the solution you are
the one that's actually going to go out
there and make those changes we're just
going to give you a little kick in the
pants give you some little advice to do
so so if you want to give us a call call
us triple eight eight two five five two
two five and we're going to just help
you out on your journey that's what
we're here to do all right let's go to
the phone line we got Joseph in Las
Vegas Nevada got that one right what's
going on Joseph
well thank you Jade warshaw for the uh
taking my phone call uh just a quick uh
thing to write cars of a debit card you
could use turo I use that all the time
just a heads up yes um
and uh I was calling in regards to a
question regarding saving and investing
um so my question is um I had a family
emergency about a year ago that's still
ongoing and I haven't been able to work
but I've been able to get paid to take
care of her loved one loved ones who are
sick and um my question is about the
best strategy for saving and putting
money aside for the future things that I
might want like uh
future vacation just to take for myself
or you know things expensive life
expenses I'm also in college too okay
and I was recently given terrible advice
by a close family friend who I love a
lot who said that you know he doesn't
think the fact that I'm going to
community college and paying cash for it
is good he says I should go to it
private Catholic School oh no did you
tell him where he can that he can put
his advice on a pipe and smoke it
[Music]
um I you know I want to tell him that
because it go ahead and go ahead and
tell him and tell him that I told you to
tell him
Joseph okay so are you a student in like
a expensive college
um I I go to a community college I'm
paying cash for tonight
you took the advice and I was like oh no
no he's doing right he's doing right
okay good I'm so sorry I'm so thankful
Joseph I thought I'd have to climb you
out of some student loan debt from a
private school okay good no Joseph is
Joseph is the man he's doing it right
good for you Joseph okay yeah and I I
just uh I I've always been anti-student
loan and you know my grandparents
they've paid off their house or Ramsey
everything except they like to use
credit cards which is one thing that I
don't like but still I really I'm not
gonna in the position to tell them what
sure what and what not to do I just live
my life and that's right
Joseph how old are you
I'm 18. you're 18. okay and you are
currently in community college and
you're helping take care of some family
members that what you said what what was
the incident that happened that put you
in this position
so my uh family members really got
recently very sick my grandfather had
covid and he ended up in the hospital
and I'll just say digressed very very
badly you know my grandmother has always
had arthritis but she usually got
diagnosed with chick cancer a few years
ago and so she was in and out of
surgeries and she has low back so it's
kind of all all kind of very and you're
put and you're put in charge of taking
care of them where are your parents I'm
just curious
um actually we've all been very
fortunate enough to live all right next
to each other so we've uh my mom works
for the my mom uh recently finished her
Masters in 2014 and moved to become uh
she works for the school district which
is here it's not good I don't know how
it is in Tennessee but not really the
way they treat their staff over there is
not good but we she's working there and
um yeah okay so what caused you Joseph
to be the primary caregiver was it
something that you volunteered because
you said okay I have I have the time uh
because I'm just in school so I can use
this as like a part-time and who's
paying you to do this because you said
you're getting paid so
um yeah that's a good question um I'm
getting paid by them they're giving me
money to your grandparents are and then
correct yeah also help take care of my
school and take care of all that stuff
so wow that's amazing Joseph yeah that's
incredible absolutely incredible and
very smart you've got great by the way
you've got great instincts
um about debt and paying for things
College
um very very good I hope that you hear
that coming from us
um so how can we help you you mentioned
that you're wanting to save for the
future you're wanting to
can you unpack that just a little bit so
we can see how to best help yeah thank
you yeah thank you so much yeah so I uh
I I've always been kind of really good
with money but I just haven't had a
direction on saving and what like the
best saving strategies are for the
future because
um you know I personally I I think that
you know as much as you invest you
should also save because you know you
have emergencies and so I want to know
what like the best saving strategy is
for money that's great well I want to
know sure so I think you're exactly
right there is a difference between
savings and investing and so we want
everyone
um to be completely debt free with an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses so we consider that your
emergency fund savings so you can put
that just in a high yield savings
account have that there and then when
you look for long-term investing that's
where um you know you're looking at
retirement funds like a 401k if your job
in the future offers that opening up a
Roth IRA and investing in that so those
are those are two great investing
options for the future but but um but I
would but I would encourage you Joseph I
mean you're 18 you have plenty of time
and people in your stage of life we
really do encourage to it sounds so
cheesy but it's like the line of
investing in yourself yeah that you have
you know a lot of life ahead of you not
just you know through college through
job change you know you may you may
decide in three years hey I have this
career passion and you get an offer in
you know Seattle or something right and
you end up moving and so there's just a
lot of change that can happen between 18
and even 22 yeah and so we always tell
people to as much cash as you can have
saved is going to be really the best bet
instead of investing which we you want
to get to later right and you're in your
early to mid-20s and you'll get there
but for right now Joseph I would really
focus on just saving that cash because
even transferring to a bigger State
School you may have the money to be like
yeah I want to get my diploma actually
from here because there's a special type
of school you want to go to or whatever
the case may be it gives you options
when you have money it gives you choices
it gives you options and if it's
invested we talk to a lot of people that
call in and they think oh gosh well I
don't want to take that money out now to
pay off debt because the Market's down
you know like you're trying to time the
market yeah and having cash available at
your age Joseph is going to be such a
game changer so that's right even coming
out of school when the time comes you
know obviously you're transitioning from
Community College eventually to
University that's going to be more
expensive and then at some point you're
going to graduate and you're going to
come out of school or maybe while you're
still you know in college you might have
the opportunity to move into your own
apartment like all of these things your
situation has the ability to change
um yes greatly at any at really at any
point so just keep your money liquid
keep it saved and then you've like
Rachel said you've got those options you
can pull from it whenever you need how
does that strike you
that honestly that you you're I love
your philosophy I love the way you laid
it out and that like I love what you
said about the saving and the investing
can come later just because of how young
I am and you know the one of the most
important things I think I've learned
from your your dad uh Rachel over the
years is that you know you want to stay
away from Death as much as you can and
when he when that family friend you know
says things like you know uh student
loan is a good debt
I feel that don't stop it's so good
Joseph and honestly man I'm telling you
this isn't me just like puffing up this
react this this fake reality the truth
is Joseph you're going to be a
multi-millionaire you are like you're
going to start investing very soon
you're going to have the cash for it
you're working now you're a smart guy
like you said you're staying away from
debt so your income is going to come in
and it's going to be all yours to help
you grow more wealth and to be generous
and give and to spend and enjoy life
like that is so powerful so powerful
Joseph and 18 years old if you start
that in your early 20s and you start
investing you aren't mathematically
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
so and somebody for you some of the some
of y'all old school listeners who have
been listening and you're still on the
fence and you're still doing the credit
card game it's like oh I love listening
to Ramsay but I still have my credit
cards take a lesson from Joseph Joseph
is taking all of us to school because
he's a young cat and he's he gets it and
so some of you guys are watching and
you're in your 30s and 40s and you're
still not sure if you're going to get on
board with this you sure you're still
deciding if it can work or if it can't
Joe
he's doing it he's taken all of us to
school so guys if this stuff works if
you work it he's going to be a
multi-millionaire what about you
you got the choice you get to decide
it's totally up to you this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
hey what's going on guys you're
listening to the Ramsay show I'm Jade
warshaw your host joined with Rachel
Cruz also hosting today uh if you want
to talk with us give us a call the
number's triple eight eight two five
five two two five but before we go to
the phone lines I am so excited to talk
about this Rachel because this for me is
like all right this is it so um a couple
of weeks back I guess it's already been
a couple weeks back I made this post
about uh when Sam and I were going
through our debt free Journey baby step
two you know of course here here at
Ramsay we're always measuring things in
terms of the baby steps right so those
are the Milestones right you hit baby
step one you get to baby step two and
you keep going and those are those mile
markers but along the way you know the
journey becomes a little bit more
personalized and you start to create
these own miles your own Milestones
throughout the journey and I remember so
on the post I was sharing I was saying
man when Sam and I were going through
this our first Milestone was can we just
pay all of our bills just using our
income because it was so tight and so
that was like thing where like if we can
just be a person that pays their bills
every month with their income not using
debt we are living like we're doing it
we're doing top of the world and then it
became okay that's great now if we can
be people who get this I just wanted to
be a person that never overdraws their
account like I can we just make it six
months without overdrawing the account
like that's the way that's how bad it
was and so that became the Milestone and
it's like then you hit that and you know
the next one comes so I was sharing that
on the internet and one of the biggest
Milestones was I if we could just Rachel
get to the point where we can buy all
four tires at once just shell out you
know 800 or 600 whatever it was that you
I'm Scrooge McDuck you can't tell me
nothing at that point right and so I
made a money in that voice I'm made of
money and so I told people I'm like tell
me tell me your Milestones I want to
know what they are and so Rachel what
people wrote it's so good I love it I
love it so good one girl wrote She Goes
girl if I can buy lunch meat from the
deli counter I made it I made it okay
this is this would be me too I love this
one not overthinking if I want guac at
Chipotle or not because they always say
it's going to be extra do you want it
and it's like and it's like 1.99 should
I notice but we're like yeah walk on I'm
good okay so too probably not doing good
you're doing good yes when you start
when you care about the calories more
than you care about the money that's
when you know it that's when you know
it's right ah this one she says
um girl when I can buy the paper the
paper and the bathroom products in the
same day as my groceries now I'm living
I love it I love it I love this someone
said yeah biggest Milestone going on a
nice vacation paid in full I appreciate
that because that's some that's some
savings right there then the vacation
doesn't follow you home in debt right oh
I love this she says oh I love this one
she goes my first Milestone was making
it to the next paycheck without having
to resort to credit cards and I feel
that yes I felt that in my soul I felt
that because you know well sometimes
everybody that uses credit cards is not
using it just to go crazy and spin some
people are really trying to just live
you know what I mean like survive their
basic needs so I felt that totally I
like this one when I could buy rib eyes
at the grocery store just because we
felt like it luxury lifestyle
it's so great
um or even this one okay this one again
Hit me hard uh Randy Rainey he says
putting the mortgage in the utilities on
autopay yes living and loving it and
that one hit me too Rachel because to
this day I think I was talking to Dave
um one day about it
before we never put anything on autopay
because it's like you don't know like
something could happen something comes
out it's the wrong time next thing you
know you've overdrawn and then maybe
something that something on autopay then
came out too and now you're overdrawn
twice in these fees and penalties are
hitting you and before you know it it's
a different type of snowball yeah effect
that's right and it's like now and today
today's financial situation I still have
that moment where I'm like
if somebody says autopay I'm like oh no
no no no and then I'm like no you know
what yeah you go ahead and put that on
autopay and it's gonna be all right it's
amazing Jay that's why I love you guys
Your Story I mean it really it's like
it's just so it's so impressive it's so
impressive and it's the and it's the the
true proof proof of like you guys all of
this yeah all of this that we're talking
about I'm like that it that it happens
and it works it's like just doing the
program and showing it I'm like it's
it's amazing and that's what I love
about even all of our hosts like yeah
Ken has a different story I have a
different story being like the second
generation the kid the second generation
of of your parents doing it all of it
I'm like every every person that sits
here and all of you listening right now
everyone has a different story of your
story you're in a different place but
here's the consistent thing is believing
that you can do it yes and that these
Milestones as as deep as some of these
feel for you Jake and as fun as some of
these are uh I think everybody relates
somehow yeah everybody and there's just
truth in owning where you are and
deciding to make progress going forward
because it may take longer for some
shorter than others but all of these
lifestyle right all this can happen
that's right and so we want you guys I I
have enjoyed this so much it's to go
told me to read these so if you have one
of those like Milestones that's like hey
Jade when I hit this point I'm living my
life please comment that put it in the
YouTube comments put in your podcast
comments or you can go on you know my
page Jade warshaw and comment I re guys
if you want me to read the comments put
them on Instagram and I'll read all of
them but um now don't fight me I don't
want to fight on the page but go go put
your comment in there but what Rachel
said is so true um at the end of the day
the way we get to these Milestones is
we've got to be intentional about our
finances right it doesn't just it's not
a magic trick that happens overnight
right for anybody I don't care where
you're at even if you're
doing well financially if you have a
great income and you just want to do
better about investing we see studies
still of people making upwards of 200
000 and they're living paycheck to
paycheck that's right so that's right
it's you're we really do learn yes does
your income help you it's your shovel to
go and like fill in the whole of debt if
you need it or you're shovel so yes it
is helpful to have a bigger shovel
obviously but also if you don't have the
habits if you don't have the discipline
to to do something with what's in the
shovel then
it's all gonna it's all gonna leave so
that's right being intentional
regardless of where you are yeah it is
it's it's okay it's so important and
that's why you know when it comes to you
know one of the classes we have here
Financial Peace University a lot of
times people will say to me but is it
only for people who are getting out of
debt or is it only for people who and
I'm like no it works no matter where
you're at in your journey no matter what
your story is if you're somebody who has
kids or don't doesn't have kids if
you're married you don't you're not
married it is a program that gives you
the information it meets you where
you're at and some of the information
you take for now some of it you put in
your pocket for later yep and it's it's
designed for you you know you take this
course it's nine classes and you will
get something out of every single class
and and we know that the reason that
we're able to get comments like this of
hey now I can order double meat at
Chipotle without checking the account
right it's because you know Rob Lopez RC
I can say his name because I actually
know him Rob went through financial
Peace University he did he committed
himself to the the nine classes he
learned the information he actually then
put it into action which is the you know
and now he's like millions of other
people who have changed their lives
simply by taking a class and committing
to yeah and Life's Too Short you guys to
be to be so stressed you know what I
mean like there's and again everyone's
in a different situation all the things
we understand that but but also that's
not an excuse not to do something like
this plan I mean honestly it is the
thing that will be able to help you
understand where your money is where it
should be going what you should be doing
with it and so that it doesn't stress
you out that's why we say Financial
Peace because we want that peace for you
we want you to sleep well at night we
want you not to feel so controlled and
so stressed over money and so we've seen
people with every debt level every
income level and again some people's
Journeys are longer shorter than others
you know the time is different but
it is possible and that's the exciting
thing and that's what um why we did this
every day the show too so I if you're
listening right now I would encourage
you to just dream a little bit and and
start thinking what's your I'm living
moment is it the next time the AC goes
out I don't want to stress I want to
know that I've got five thousand dollars
if I have to replace it in an emergency
fund yeah right okay start dreaming
start seeing how your life would change
if you put on a plan if you got on you
know a plan for your money if you paid
off your debt if you had savings start
dreaming because that's when you're
gonna start having the motivation to
actually make these changes stronger the
why the stronger the try this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on you're listening to
the Ramsay show I'm your host Jade
warshaw joined to the right by Rachel
Cruz uh guys give us a call we would
love to take your call talk about your
life talk about your money and by the
way I know I probably speak for both of
us when I say it's such a privilege that
you guys call us to talk about something
as personal as your money you don't even
talk some of y'all not even talking to
your spouses about the money but you're
calling us to talk about it so we do not
take that lightly give us a call Triple
A
825-5225 and now we're going to Brian in
New York City New York what's going on
Brian how can we help
Hi how are you thanks for taking my call
we're doing good how are you
um
pretty good um so I just got a new uh
role at work with a bit of a pay bump
and we're currently in the New Jersey
area and we're thinking uh my wife and I
in about 18 months moving down to South
Carolina where I'll become the Sole
Provider just much cheaper cost of
living and I work remote from home and
my wife would be able to be a
stay-at-home mother with our three kids
and the problem we're into right now is
my daughter starts school in September
and so we need a second car we've been
dealing with one car we just haven't
needed a second one
and so we need a second car we have been
saving this past year or so we have the
cash ready to go
um but there's a chance we again won't
need a second car once we moved down
there because I work from home but we
probably will in a couple years so I
hate the idea of like leasing a car but
we're curious to your thoughts on would
it make sense in our city situation to
lease a car for like 18 months to then
not have to travel down with it and
especially if we don't know if we'll
need it
why can't you just buy a used car and
sell it if you don't want to take it to
North Carolina when you go
I only say that because leasing is the
most expensive way to own to operate a
vehicle vehicle not own it operate it
and it you're just throwing so much
money down the drain the way the
payments are structured and the way it's
set up it's it's a horrible horrible
idea if I were in your shoes I would buy
something in cash how much do you have
saved I wouldn't buy something expensive
I just buy something that's point a
point B and when it's time to move to
South Carolina 28k or so
um yeah you don't have to spend 28k
unless you think you're going to want to
keep it and drive it down when you go
do you guys have any debt Brian where
are you guys at financially
um no we we were debt free outside of
the house right now awesome how much do
you guys make a year
uh I'm at a 100K now and my wife is at
92 so we should be getting down to the
100. yeah I mean I'm with Jade I'm like
I'd go get a used car because because
someone else has already taken the major
hit of it being depreciated you know
maybe maybe a four or five year old car
um and the used car market still is a
little wacky so honestly in 18 months
it's probably not going to go that much
down and follow you
um so yeah so that I would just sell it
and and you guys have a great income and
so I would even say you keep it for now
and then when you and then sell it and
then when you guys get to South Carolina
kind of see how your life is and see
what you have saved then maybe get a
nicer car right if it's a car you're
going to be keeping for a while you guys
can afford it so
um yeah it's a 28 000 Above and Beyond
at emergency fund or is that all the
money you guys have saved uh that's
that's all in uh what we have in savings
right now completely okay so I would I
would partial out you know I mean I
would honestly partial out Brian more
like on the sixth month because of this
map that's possibly coming
um so that may not leave you with as
much so if 28 if you have 28 000 saved
how much do you think how much is like a
month's worth of expenses for you guys
um in New Jersey right now probably
about three thousand three thousand
yeah okay that's great yeah yeah so yeah
I would
yeah I would keep that as as part of
that as the emergency fund
um I mean I get I mean around 18 so that
leaves you about 10 to get a car for
your wife to take the kids to and from
school for 18 months so it's not gonna
be a pretty car it's not gonna be when
she's like super probably proud of but
that's okay because it's going to get
you guys from point A to point B and
you're not going into a contract like a
lease and you'll be happy to have it
when you go from one car to two cars
you're just happy to have a second view
yeah
so I'm thinking I'm thinking she'll be
like this is great I don't have to we
don't have to do that coordination that
is required when you have one vehicle
right yeah yeah definitely and this will
be for me to drive just to drop off uh
kids the younger kids and my
mother-in-law's but my thought process
was that would you know it would roughly
cost us I did the numbers about 7 000
for the lease
um and that would just leave us with
more money to put towards the new house
well it leaves you seven thousand
dollars with the lease but then you have
no you have you don't have something at
the end of the lease
yeah that's true yeah I'd rather put
money into something where I have some
ownership at the end as opposed to just
empty payments it's like renting
yeah it's renting a car why do that
yeah okay thank you so much did we can
did we convince you
yeah I think I'm convinced or even take
this or even take your math Brian and do
the 7 000.
and then you're you got seven thousand
dollars like you haven't like lost much
because you'll sell the seven thousand
dollar car and then there you go I don't
know like versus seven thousand dollars
just being down the drain that's in the
lease like what Jade's saying yeah all
right awesome thanks Brian thanks for
the call yeah I hope I don't I don't
know that we fully convinced him but I
hope that we did yeah guys when it comes
to those leases they are they're
terrible what they what they pulled into
that payment how they determine what
your payment is with the cost of capital
and the wear and tear and like you're in
what you said is absolutely right unless
you you know go through the whole thing
and buy it out at the end you're left
with nothing yes terrible car stuff
y'all it's like it's my least favorite
debt if I can say it you know what I
mean I'm like I it because it's a
depreciating asset I'm like it's going
down in value so whether it's leasing or
it's car payments mathematically
speaking it is like oh it's such a drain
it's such a dream for something with
four wheels to get you from point A to
point B you know oh yeah and you I mean
we've had this conversation before in in
viral proportions you know how I feel
about it because they are what keep in a
lot of cases not necessarily in our Guy
Brian he's just trying to move but for a
lot of people their car payment is
what's keeping them from everything they
want yeah financially in life because
their car payment is somewhere between
five and seven hundred dollars for just
one yeah for just one and they're
wondering why I can't pay my student
loan when it comes due in September or
you're wondering why I can't put 15 away
for retirement or you're wondering why I
can't seem to pay these bills off and
I'm like you have probably somewhere
from five to a thousand dollars if
there's two yeah yeah that's real money
and you're giving that away just so you
can have a what a 2023 Camry for a Camry
Rachel giving that future away for the
camera okay it's not worth it it's not
worth it and so that's why we're always
telling people man just either pay off
your car early pay it off as quickly as
you can within the debt snowball and
then when you go to purchase a car again
buy it in cash yes and like what we're
saying I love I was talking to Ken on
this show and he was looking for used
cars for his teenager and he was like
the amount of car between five and ten
thousand there are so many yeah they are
so many and some of them are great are
great cars and honestly if you're not a
car person you don't know the year that
something's made like oh yeah like you
don't know and uh yeah and maybe it's uh
not to be serious but maybe it's a guy
thing I don't know I guess some girls
love cars but I'm like it just and again
I like a great car me too I'm not mad at
you we're not mad at nice cars although
can I tell you I'm like it's it's like
it's just it's it's just it's just wild
to me of what people were paying car
payments it's not worth it and like for
a car you made such a good point most
people have no clue my uh Sam and I've
got finally have two vehicles but one's
a 2012 and one's a 2013 and we bought
them in 2018 and in 2023 so they they
were never brand new cars but when my my
brother was over at the house this
weekend and he saw our newer vehicle and
he goes oh that that car is so nice and
I'm thinking to myself it's a 2013 like
it's so old but it's it's well kept but
it's in good condition and look get get
it get it in Black if you get it in
Black everything looks much better if
it's an old car get it in the color
black because it's still shiny it looks
better don't get red and definitely
don't get like a weird like mustard okay
is what Jade is saying it's Timeless no
one will know the difference and you'll
have something what is known as money in
your pocket what a life what a time to
be alive all right that does it for this
hour of the show be sure to join us next
time guys this is where we're getting it
done this is where we're making changes
this is where things happen so be sure
to tune in next time this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we hang out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money the things that are concerning you
I'm your host Jade warshaw joined by
Rachel Cruz who's also host of The
Rachel Cruz show and smart money happy
hour and the list just goes on and on
and on it's really great but you can
give us a call today and we will give
you our input Our advice what we would
do if we were in your shoes so give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we will
take your call in the meantime let's go
to Michael in Mobile Alabama what's
going on Michael
good afternoon ladies how y'all doing
doing good how are you
I'm doing great
um so me and my wife have recently
started FPU
um and we're on baby step number two
and we have there's been a lot of
excitement you know seeing the snowball
you know rolling down the hill paying
debts off and the question I have is
um when we reached out to friends and
family you know
just telling them hey this is what we're
doing and you know this is what it's
doing in our lives we get a lot of
negativity and I was just curious you
know why why people are so negative
about stuff like this and then also how
can we build a support group you know
with like-minded people that that you
know have shared our journey and and can
encourage us and US encouraging them
yeah
um number one I'm I'm really proud of
you guys for taking control of your
situation I mean you mentioned that
you're in Financial Peace University
which is our course for getting control
of your money and you're in baby step
two paying off this debt so I'm really
proud of you guys and yeah a lot of
people when they're in that phase they
they are met you know with some
opposition it's like you're sharing this
journey you're hoping that you're going
to get the support of your family and
friends and sometimes you do
um and sometimes you do later on down
the line but you know to your point I
think sometimes what happens Michael is
at least what I have found is sometimes
when you make the strides to better
yourself in any area it could be health
and wellness it could be financially
spiritually it has the tendency to
become a mirror for other people and
when you're saying oh I'm I'm on a
budget I'm making smart choices with my
money yes it would be great if people
said good for you I'm proud of you way
to go way to be a responsible adult but
instead it kind of holds up that mirror
to them and maybe not in every case but
maybe they are starting to see oh I like
I should do better with my finances and
I should be you know and they start to
run through this checklist in their mind
and it maybe kind of makes them feel bad
or guilty or weird and sometimes that
um comes out as a little bit of haterade
you know what I'm saying it comes out a
little bit like oh really you know well
good luck with that you know and they
get a little funky fresh but
I want to encourage you that as you go
through this I bet you you'll start to
see that change because they're going to
start to see the fruit that it's having
in your life they're going to start to
see those wonderful outcomes from what
you're doing and the smart folks are
going to start asking you how you did it
yeah and I think Michael too they're you
know regardless of what they're saying
which I know this is easier said than
done
um you know there's a there's a
confidence that you and your wife have
to have in each other and in this
process that you just say okay you know
we're choosing to make these decisions
regardless of what people think or not
um we're choosing to do this and I think
jade made a good point too that you know
it can be a mirror for other people but
also Michael I've learned when you get
healthier in a part of your life whether
it's you know you're doing therapy and
it's the emotional side if it's in your
money and you're actually making
progress there and in control whether
it's wellness and you're actually
watching what you're eating and thinking
about taking care of your body like
whatever the thing is or your marriage
and you're like working really hardcore
in your marriage like whatever this the
season of life that you're getting
healthier in it can start to feel lonely
because there are a lot of people that
don't do the work on themselves and so
it starts to even magnify
the other unhealth around you so so when
you're on this you're like I never
would have thought about you know people
using credit cards or uh taking out car
loans but now that you're in it and
you're trying to get out and you're
working so hard when someone says I got
a car loan it's gonna feel bigger to you
yeah and it's probably going to magnify
a little bit more to you because of what
you're walking through so that so that's
on more of your side than the other
people but I think regardless of what
the other people are saying or doing you
have to I think finding that Community
is really key and this sounds so cheesy
because we always say your Facebook
friends aren't your real friends but
there's like the baby steps community on
Facebook like there's people all around
the internet you know may not be next
door to you physically but there's so
much support that I have found with
people uh you know whether it's on you
know Facebook or Instagram that are part
of these groups or if you're in an FPU
class and it's your class that you're
talking to like even on the show like
listening to the show and hearing that
there's other people doing what you're
doing yes it's just encouragement so uh
whether it's community that you find
which would be ideal in person that it's
actual friends may be walking the
journey with you that's a that's an
ideal situation but if you even if you
don't find that you can find people all
over the place doing this stuff so I
would encourage you guys because you're
not alone in it so I don't want you to
feel isolated either yeah and and stick
it out because
um sometimes if you let those voices
carry too much weight you can let them
shift you off course and I wouldn't I I
hate I've seen that happen sometimes
it's like oh well I've been on the plan
for a while and you kind of get
comfortable and then whoever it is like
just keeps chatting in your ear about
you know why why it's good to have a
credit card for the points and before
you know it you're like well maybe I
should you know so just stand strong and
like be firm in what you've decided and
just understand that sometimes when
people are negative
it says probably has nothing to do it
actually has zero to do with you and way
more to do about whatever is going on in
their life and there's probably you know
because money too Michael as you
probably know
creates a lot of insecurity a lot of
fear like it's not a very happy topic
for a lot of people which we hate that's
why we do this show because we're like
we want to spread hope and help people
have the opposite effects when it comes
to their money but
um as you guys start to gain traction
like Jade said I think for a lot of
people that can be
um it can stir up a lot of their own
fear and security too what do you think
Michael does that hit you right
yes ma'am it did and and the whole
reason that me and my wife started stu
um was because you know my best friend
him and his wife had went through it and
you know they paid off all their their
debts in their house and we got us
talking one day and he's like I'm gonna
gift you a free year of Ramsay Plus for
you and I was like really he's like yeah
he's like I've been wanting to do this
for a year he's like but I've never
hadn't found that right person to give
it to
um he's like you know all the people I
know they're not going to take it
serious and he's like I want somebody to
really use this and he's like I feel
like you you and your wife will so
that's how we got started with it and
I'm really appreciative to him for that
Michael we just started a month ago and
and the the momentum is just incredible
yes love to hear it I love that Michael
and I'm tempted I'm going to I'm going
to do this I want to do it Austin to
pick up because Michael I want to gift
you I get a gift card because we have
like the live and give bundle or we have
we have the ability to get you a gift
card for you Michael then to pass on
what your friend to you so I want you to
hold on to this I want you guys to get
through FPU from that gift from your
friend and then when you guys finish and
graduate I want you as a couple to find
another couple and do that with and keep
that keep that chain moving Georgetown
George hates the generosity chain at
Starbucks but I'm doing one for for FPU
right now well as long as you don't make
it creepy and be like don't break the
chain if you break the chain something
evil is gonna happen as long as you just
do it nicely and say hey man pass it on
that's how you do a generosity train
change not in weird creepy
pseudo-religious ways
nice pass it on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 percent off selected
products visit blinds.com today for more
info
[Music]
thank you
hey what's going on guys you're
listening to the Ramsey Show I'm Jade
warshaw this is Rachel Cruz we're taking
calls about your life your financial
situation although I'll be honest the
word Financial sometimes it feels a
little like highbrow yeah a little yes
Hi Brow Rachel I like the word money
money feels like everybody's got it it's
it's it's accessible so if you want to
talk about your money we will talk about
it triple eight eight two five five two
two five and um that's what we do on the
show and while I'm talking about that I
really want to encourage if you listen
to this show regularly or if you just
recently found it and you're like this
show is the business I want to tell my
friends about it please do that tell
your friends that you love this show
share an episode with them if it's you
know an episode you really loved that's
a great one that you could share talk
about it on social media like subscribe
you can even leave a comment however
just leave kind comments
um some people like myself in George
Campbell like to look at the comments so
don't be saying anything crazy because
we're real people with real feelings but
anyway no say what you feel is a free
country we're gonna do what we do anyway
but like subscribe and share the show
all right
Rachel uh I kind of want to talk about
something here and that is this idea of
we call it gazelle intensity yeah okay
so if you're listening for the first
time you're probably like what the heck
is that
explain please now obviously you can go
and get more information by going to
ramseysolutions.com is clicking that get
started button because we have all this
lingo and terminology around here and
whenever we're talking about baby step
two which is paying off all your debt
smallest to largest using the debt
snowball all right that's a Crux of all
the things that we do around here
um but we talk about this concept of
being gazelle intense and there's more
behind that that I feel like is
necessary to unpack because the way this
the way this plan works it it is
contingent on you doing all the steps
and you doing the steps the way that
we're teaching it right because part of
paying off your debt we might tell you
hey pause retirement temporarily so you
can get that money back so you can have
more money to pay off this debt quickly
but if you're out if you're out here
lollygagging around and you're like oh
yeah I'm gonna pay off my debt I'm
pausing my retirement I'm paying off my
debt but you know a little here and
there and I'm just I mean you could mess
around and this thing could take you a
decade and you've paused your retirement
for a decade that's not what we're
saying what we're saying is we want you
to go as intense as possible and the way
your dad Dave Ramsey has always
explained it is a a cheetah chasing a
gazelle right in in the wilderness right
and that gazelle is like cheetah and
he's running and he's trying to get away
from it and the cheetah is dead right
the cheetah is trying to eat your butt
and so you've got to get away from that
so that's that's one of the reasons we
say gazelle intensity
um because there's a scripture in
Proverbs that says yeah if you've signed
Surety my son if you've gotten yourself
into debt because that means do this and
it says give no sleep to your eyes no
Slumber to your eyelids and deliver
yourself like a gazelle from the hands
of the hunter there you go and it's this
like powerful imagery of a gazelle
running for its life as you watch the
cheetah yeah you kind of think of that
Discovery Channel moment yeah and and
it's and like that's the intensity in
Proverbs what it says and again rather
you believe you know in the Bible that
doesn't matter Proverbs is just a great
book in general right yeah of wisdom and
it's like yeah if you want to get out of
debt do this and it's like you have to
run like your life depends on and we say
it all the time Jade you can wander your
way into debt but you cannot wander your
way out like this has to be intense yeah
I I yeah um
it's just there's a screen we're talking
about scripture I gotta hit one more
because this is the way it talks about
the thief it says the thief comes to
steal kill and destroy and you know I'm
like okay that sounds like debt to me
debt it comes in it's stealing your
income right it's destroying your your
relationships it's destroyed it's
destroying your peace you know it's it's
it's killing your hope it's a thief and
you've got to get yourself away from
that as quickly as possible so gazelle
intensity is that idea of scorched earth
right we're cutting our budget down to
Bare Bones as as much as we can we're
not doing all these extra things all
these extra subscriptions we're not
going out to eat guys we're not we're
not you know going on and buying a bunch
of clothes we're just getting what we
need and then in addition to that we're
probably finding ways to increase our
income
um right and so the whole point of this
is as much money as we can get our hands
on to throw at this debt snowball we
don't want to kick this can down the
road we want to move quickly and so a
lot of you might know uh Sam and I's
story which you know we had 460 000 of
debt to pay off and I'll be honest in
the beginning we weren't it's not Rachel
like we tallied it up and we were like
let's see what we have to be that would
have been so depressing
um we it was like we listed them but we
never like added the total number maybe
I don't know maybe the Lord told us
never do that because you you'll never
make it but um we listed them smallest
to largest and it was like okay we're
going to be in this for the Long Haul
and there's something about being
gazelle intense that you go to these
extremes and I think sometimes people
comment or they call in and there's like
this incredulous like do I really have
to do that
and yeah you might you might have to do
that
um I remember there was a time where our
budget was cut down so low I was
spending sixty dollars
um a week and I would get the 60 and
at the time I would usually just go
whatever the ad whatever was on sale I
would buy that at the store it was for
60 for groceries yes for groceries
whatever was on sale I would just buy
that and you know make it happen and I
remember I had such a like detailed list
at one point my husband and I were in
the store and I look in the car and I
see this package of oatmeal in the cart
I'm like why is that in there like
that's not on the list you know we got
sixty dollars what's happening and my
husband we had bid in the journey at
that point for like four and a half five
years oh wow yeah and he's looking at me
he goes oh I put that in there and I'm
like it's not on the list he goes yeah
but it's it's like it's like 1.99 and
I'm like it's not on the list and so
we're like standing there in the car
like face to face like laser like laser
beams going through between our eyes
like having this Face-Off moment over
oatmeal and I finally said to him I was
like we're so like honestly I feel
myself getting a little bit choked up
now because I'm like we're so close
every bit counts like every bit counts
you have to put it back and I kid you
not my husband's eyes started tearing up
and I was like are you are you gonna cry
right now he was like I'm just so ready
to be done with this and those moments
are so real and and people will will
play you online and act like oh your
latte every day doesn't count it's just
1.99 don't let those Ramsay people tell
you that you can't get your latte folk
you can't get your latte you can't get
it this time and that's okay make your
coffee at home what is the big deal
we're big boys and big girls and we can
make these sacrifices and we can do them
for a limited time only and change our
life for the rest of our life it's so
worth it if you're on the fence and
you're like man it's not worth it live
for today I'm like no it is worth it it
is so worth it to pursue something
greater because it's not going to just
affect you it's going to affect the
people around you the guy that called
earlier for and some people say well I
don't have kids it doesn't matter it
affects the people around you you when
people see you doing something
counter-cultural that's making your life
better they have questions and they're
going oh wait we can do this like people
can actually be debt free people can
actually have savings people can
actually be millionaires in their 30s
and they're in their 40s what are you
saying yes but it requires sacrifice
gazelle intensity is what it requires
short term short-term sacrifice for
long-term gains so good Jade it's so
good and I think too the point that you
said limited time because that's it too
like we're not these crazy people asking
you to live like this and not get two
dollar oatmeal for the rest of your life
no we're not saying that but for a
period of time the deeper you sacrifice
yep the deeper you sacrifice and the
more consistent you are in it the faster
you're gonna get out which means the
faster you get back to your life that's
right and do what you want to do but
it's it takes that level of it and we
and we hear these calls every day and
people stand on their debt-free stage
here in the lobby with sharing their
stories and you guys
I'm over here seven and a half years
that's not normal please understand 18
18 to 24 months on average but if you
have to go seven years you're living
proof that you're still here that yeah
still standing you're still standing for
Friday and life is okay so it's it's
impressive life is good to you and Sam
for sure man Incredible Journey you guys
walked you guys can do it too we're not
special we're not super human we're just
normal folks following a plan and you
can do it too I don't care who you are
your background what you make what you
don't make or the color of your skin you
can do this this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey what's going on you're listening to
the Ramsey Show I'm Jade warshaw your
host this is Rachel Cruz to my right and
we're taking calls all afternoon long we
got a couple segments left so give us a
call Triple A
825-5225 in the meantime let's go to
Keisha May in New York City New York
what's going on Keisha oh my God I can't
believe it oh hi hey what's up how are
you guys how are you I'm hanging in
there you thank you so much for taking
my call of course how can we help
um so I had a two-part question but uh
you kind of nailed it with the baby step
one for the second question
um but my first question is I'm in kind
of a
a dilemma
I am a registered nurse in the emergency
department we are on baby step two we
currently make uh I make 105k and my
husband makes 45k
I will be transitioning to a new
position there's partition or physician
but I have to decide between the two
okay and
um one of them pays
147k and the other ones page 130k okay
but I'm looking to work at a four day
week so the one that pays more is
offering the four day week the one that
pays less is a five day week but the
commute is not as bad as the one that
pays more okay so
um and then my other part of that how
much more commute sorry how big is the
commute what's the difference so
so the 130k commute is about 50 minute
drive and the 147 is an hour and 20
minutes okay so 30 minutes more okay
and um they're both non-unionized I'm
currently in a union position now
um that if I stick with it I can be
rested in the pension by May of next
year
now my question was
do I choose the one with the higher
amount because around the east of two in
addition to keeping the very highly
stressful job that I have now uh if I
work part-time I get to keep my
attention and my medical benefits
um working every Sunday for a year and a
half
or do I pick the one with the letter
commute taking the slight pink cut as an
MP
while still keeping my emergency room
job or do I just like hey I'm young I
can just save up the money for detention
and just
yeah you know yeah I wouldn't let a
pension be the thing that sways this
decision for me
um so I mean an hour difference in
commute basically if it's 30 minutes One
Way 30 minutes the other I mean an hour
is that's significant that's a
significant time and because you have
kids right
yeah I have two kids yeah so that's
significant to me that almost adds up to
the full work day
if you really think about it an hour for
you know it's half a work day it's for
four hours a week which is half of a
normal work day
yeah with the emergency room job that
you could keep with the 130 job the 130
000 and with that emergency job the
emergency room job what is that what are
the benefits there again did you say
health insurance
so I get to keep my health insurance
which is excellent and then I get to
continue to stay on my way to these
vested fully vested into the pension oh
okay with the other one okay but it
would be a five day a week which is kind
of a lot oh that's right yeah it will be
five days Monday through Friday nine to
five in addition to the Sunday
emergency room job is there is there any
flexibility a year from now where they
would
take you down hours
no no unfortunately not okay and how
much you guys have left in your debt
so we still have a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars less than debt and 107
is of student loans okay
whoo this is tough um I agree with
Rachel the pension wouldn't be the thing
that decides it for me I
ah
because of your day and I'm sorry I
wanted to clarify one other thing did
you say your husband makes 45k or 145.
he makes 40 45 okay 105. got it okay
um
I honestly this is just me I honestly
think that
there's not a wrong choice here
um I don't think there's a wrong choice
I think there's what serves your
situation best either way you're working
you know working six days if you do the
other one and you're working six days a
week that's a lot but you're also you
know you're working the baby steps so
there's a season where there is a lot of
work
um if you do the four day a week one
you're losing a little bit of time in
the commute but all things considered I
think you're going to end up having more
time for more money I think the way I'm
looking at it unless I'm missing
something Rachel so I I feel like I
would go
with a higher paying job and the less
the less amount of days even though
there's a slightly longer commute yeah
um I think it's going to get you where
you want to go quicker and the second
the thing is there's always a sacrifice
there's always a rub so here are the
sacrifices a third you know 30 minutes
more in the morning 30 minutes more in
the afternoon but I think you're going
to be feeling better if whatever day you
have off Friday you're going to be like
yes I have all day yes and you're
getting paid 17 000 more doing that yeah
so that's what makes sense to me I I
don't know that the let me be clear the
other choice is not wrong or there's
it's not it's not bad I just think that
the first option is the better choice in
my opinion
what do you think
I think that sounds I was leaning more
towards that but yeah
um yeah I was definitely because I was
like I wanted to be gazelle intense and
like I said my part two question was I
was one of the people that were fooled
about the student loan thing about the
forgiveness and I'm like Oh yay we're
gonna get forgiven especially you know
being you know a nurse during the
pandemic I was like yes and then it
didn't happen and I'm like oh crap yeah
now I gotta go pay these bad boys well I
love that you're thinking ahead and you
guys are making great money too so just
know that they're like like this 147 is
going to be so helpful and paying off
this debt and if you guys continue just
to keep sacrificing and what Jade was
saying in the segment before living that
lifestyle Bare Bones you're gonna be
able to get out of this so much faster
and then you look up in three years two
and a half years and it's like okay what
do I want to do with my life if there's
no bills to be paid no it has to be paid
then maybe you take even a lesser paying
job closer to home three days a week
or if you want right so all the options
continue to flow in such a good point
where you have that so it changes the
way you work that's good Jade I'm with
you I think option one I hate I always
hate a longer commute I know but for
seventeen thousand dollars and less and
one less day yeah yeah yeah yes I agree
I really do think so and by the way
Keisha made a very good point the
student loans are coming back and she is
doing the proactive thing which I think
many people need to be doing right now
which is looking at your current
situation and asking yourself does
anything need to change do I need to be
looking for different work do I need to
be looking for side hustles do I need to
be finding ways to shift My Lifestyle so
that I can and get this not only pay the
minimum payment but pay it off okay and
I can't say this enough I'm probably
gonna beat this drum a lot in James our
producer is probably going to be like
hey stop talking about it but right now
when these loans come back guys all of
these service providers are going to try
to convince you to do an income based
repayment plan they're going to say oh
it's going to be tough for you to make
this payment do a lower payment and some
of these payment plans that they're
proposing are five five percent of your
discretionary income that's nothing yeah
and and when I can cover the interest
that doesn't thank you Rachel it barely
even covers the interest and so what
happens is and you see it all the time
people complain and they and they go
wait a second I've been making these
payments but somehow my my bill keeps
going up somehow the balance keeps going
up this thing is rigged this thing is
jacked and I'm like no you're on an
income-based plan and and if you're not
attacking at least all of the interest
and getting some towards the principal
it will never go down and I don't say
that to be hopeless I say that to say do
you pay as much as you can pay not as
little as you can pay and if you want
more information about that go check out
our documentary borrowed feature that's
where we're really uncovering uh what's
going on with these student loans and
guys don't wait start being proactive
look at this stuff now see what your
payment's gonna be look at your budget
see if you have the money and and and
don't bury your head in the sand when it
comes to your money ignorance is not
Bliss it's broke do not bury your head
in the sand on this we're here to help
you if you need the help this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
all right you're listening to the Ramsay
show I'm your host Jade warshaw this is
Rachel Cruz and as always we're taking
your calls we enjoy sitting here talking
to you guys about your situation your
life your money uh in the scripture and
quote of the day is up next it says
whoever walks in Integrity walks
securely but whoever takes crooked paths
will be found out that's proverbs 10 9
and then Kenny Loggins said this come on
Austin with the Kenny Loggins the more
honest you can be the less you have to
hide when I have nothing to hide I have
everything to do that was good that's a
good one that's a good one I feel that
one's got like a couples sharing their
money Vibes right look I'm always going
to put that out there and by the way um
just want to kind of let you guys know a
little bit of information uh we have a
really great newsletter here
um available to you guys anybody who's
listening uh it's our Ramsay Solutions
newsletter and it's filled with all
these great tips it's wonderful uh it
says work from home jobs have exploded
the past few years and Americans
enthusiasm for remote work is still
going strong cool so if you're ready for
a new opportunity outside of the office
working from home could be a good option
from you for you so this week we're
breaking down the 15 best work from home
options simply sign up at
ramsesolutions.com newsletter to
subscribe or our Sunday newsletter and
learn how to re to make remote work your
reality wow that was a mouthful
um yeah I love this because I think that
there's so many moms who want more time
staying at home and would love to figure
out how they can do some work from home
whilst you kind of have an eye on their
kids or like do like that partial
daycare day and yes sometimes work from
home is a great opportunity for that so
some flexibility yeah man check out the
newsletter we're always dropping little
nuggets of wisdom like that for you all
right this is is Diane from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania what's going on Diane
hi Jade hi Rachel thank you so much for
taking my call hey
I am trying to figure out
what to do here
um without even realizing it it looks
like I'm on baby step two okay so I have
about a total of 21 600 in debt 16
000 of that is a home equity okay line
of credit
so between my car and some credit cards
they come out to about fifty four
hundred dollars I have right around
fifteen thousand dollars in my savings
right now
so what I'm wondering is
whether to take out
the fifty four hundred dollars pay off
everything except the home equity
throw everything else
at at the home equity which I'm figuring
would probably take me about the thunder
three years to get it paid off unless I
do a good Purge through my house and I
have some things that I could sell
trying to figure out really don't have
a retirement plan my house is pretty
much my retirement plan what's your
homework at the moment
um 400 to 425 000. how much do you owe
on it
well that's the thing I don't pay
there's it's going to be paid off in
2025 it's being paid off by my
ex-husband so I do not have a mortgage
okay okay that's good
and it'll be paid off and almost like a
year and a half in 2025 yeah there's
only about thirty five thousand dollars
that's great that's wonderful what's
your income each month
um
let's see
a gross about forty five thousand seven
hundred right now I have a raise coming
up this month and another raise that
will come up in January
so
puts me at a gross of I figure after
this month when I get the raise I should
I should gross about
um
no not gross but actually net of about 2
800 a month
2 800 a month okay
yeah
um so
your situation I would walk it through
the baby steps just like any other
situation so I think you've got the
right idea which is you're taking this
15K that you have saved and you are
dispersing that you're keeping a
thousand out just for that you know
starter emergency fund and you're
throwing the rest at your debt to to
tackle that as quickly as possible and
then I do think like you said Diane go
through your home and sell the things
that you can sell because gazelle
intensity we want to go quickly and pay
this debt off as fast as possible how
much money Diane real quick do you think
you could get like what are the things
around your house that you see that
you're like I could probably get some
are we talking like 300 bucks or like
three thousand dollars right
oh
probably close to ten thousand maybe
that's wonderful wow Diane yeah totally
totally I tried to start a business and
I actually have a laser machine which
if I sell that and some of the supplies
that I have I should be able yes there
you go well all that I mean let's just
pretend you can get that uh with this 15
then you're gonna be for sure done with
the 21 000 oh yeah Dan that's that's the
gold right there because we talked about
in order to pay off debt sacrificing
lifestyle upping income and selling
stuff for your three best like Avenues
and most people they just kind of have
crap around their house and they can
sell it on Facebook Marketplace and get
some cash right but if you have large
equip if you have like equipment like
what you're talking about to bring some
cash into I mean I would do that today
yeah because you'll have money left over
so if you sell that for 10 000 and
you've got the 40 000 left over you have
some left over to get that jump start
back to the three to six months yeah
saved up yep
I like it so you're gonna take that 15
000 UF saved You're Gonna Keep a
thousand dollars of it
and for yourself there's no problem
there too because my daughter's getting
married in a couple of months and I
still have a little bit of obligation
what are your obligations
well I have to pay a balance on the
hotel for going uh she's being getting
married out of state so
I have and her shower which I've already
committed to so that's not four thousand
dollars though no no no no it's not four
thousand it's about
uh
because you should let me let me walk
through how much is it 1200
1200. let's get to the point I'm hoping
and when is the wedding
October you should be able to cash flow
this I think because if you sell the
laser machine you like you we said
you've got the 15K plus the 10K from the
cell of the laser machine that clears
your debt plus gives you 4 000 extra so
you've got this cushion here
um and then you've got your normal cash
flow so let's start setting money aside
now because we're paying off this debt
without even touching your normal cash
flow right so let's start setting aside
money now to start paying for the hotel
room is there anything any make a list
of anything else you think you might
have to pay for and put the amount next
to it and let's start setting aside
sinking funds and getting this money
aside for the wedding
it's not going to be like uh overnight
sale that's the only um that's worried
about how long that could take maybe
maybe a month right I mean if you go and
put it up Post-it places
um look into the industry that people
need that type of machine and right you
know I mean I mean that's that that's
gonna send I mean like I hate to put all
the eggs in the laser machine basket but
there it will it will help Propel you
forward so I want you to be motivated
to sell it you know for what it's worth
obviously but to at least Market it and
like let people know that you have this
because that's fantastic but what Jade's
saying is right that you know once you
pay this off though what's amazing Diane
is that that 2800 that you have coming
in is not going to be going back out to
payments anymore like you'll get you'll
you're keeping that to go and do what
you need to it in your life and that'll
be building up that emergency fund and
then that's going to be really focused
on
um on retirement and I know you're a
home you said is that and that's what's
tough about you know when we talk about
um funding retirement in your home as we
always say we don't want all of we don't
want you to go and just pay off your
home because some people want to go and
do that and not fund retirement so like
we don't want you stuck with a paid for
house but no cash that's right uh and so
in your case though Diane obviously this
is such a gift that you have this home
and it'll be paid off soon
um but I want you to start you know you
know sitting down even with the smart
investor Pro and walking through what
retirement looks like because you may
still have to work you know for for for
a few years and not retire you know at
65 you may be working just to get
yourself in a good place that if you
decide to downsize your home and still
own property which is ideal you can take
the equity of some of that put in
retirement so you have some puzzle
pieces here in the future there but it's
not a hopeless situation not a hopeless
situation you have a lot of options
which is great I love it all right guys
that does it for today's show and
remember guys when it comes to your life
and your money you can make changes you
can tell me that you won't do it but
never tell me that you can't all things
are possible with Christ Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]